[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome to scene at the
academy i'm dave karger from
turner classic movies this installment
is about the beautiful film
nomad land and i'm so happy to have six
members
of this wonderful casting crew here with
me to talk about the film so let me
introduce them first of all
writer director editor and producer
chloe zhao
also with us actor and producer francis
mcdormand
cinematographer and production designer
joshua james richards
and producers peter spears who also acts
in the film
molly asher and dan jan v hello to all
of you great to see you all
hey how are you hi francis let me start
with you because i feel like
the communities of the nomads
and also the seasonal workers are so
intertwined in this movie
how do you see the two communities
connected with each
other i think one of the most
interesting things about the
life of the van dwellers is that it is
nomadic and they
travel from season to season and from
job to job
and they are literally the migrant force
workforce
of america right now uh
as well as the undocumented citizens
that
fuel our workforce in america and i
think that one of the things that was
really exciting for all of us was to
go to the actual work places where the
work is done
amazon fulfillment centers sugar beet
harvests in nebraska
uh working at the the as hosts
you know we i worked as a host at um
the badlands national park and i think
to see people at work it's like fern
says she likes work she needs work
that's why we're all here on this tape
together too
we like work yeah
josh when i watch the scenes in the van
i think to myself
how did you even do that how many crew
members could you fit
in that van to get everything done that
you needed to do
yes it was quite a squeeze um
that question comes up quite a lot
actually for some reason
uh yeah i mean thank goodness the
cameras are growing smaller and smaller
nowadays
um and the technology is there to get
cameras into
you know different environments and
places and to get close to it
in ways that you haven't seen before um
yeah shooting inside vanguard was
was most of the experience really it
seems it feels like most of my memories
like me and fran
doing a sort of dosey doe inside the van
and
cursing ourselves that we didn't build
one on a stage or something
um but you know hopefully there's an
authenticity to shooting in those real
places so
hopefully it comes across chloe when i
watch these beautiful montages which
tell us so much about
fern's life and the way that she's
existing day to day
i think to myself i'm curious to know if
you had all of that kind of planned out
almost like in a storyboard form or was
it more of a question of
shooting as much as you could and then
dealing with all of that
in the editing room and putting it all
together then
i'd like to think that everything that i
have on screen is exactly how i planned
it and how i want it to be
yeah that would be a better answer but
no uh uh it was 50
50. we knew from very early on
that it's going to be not just a passing
through
space but also time um so we knew
we we plotted out the season changes
and the location the palette of the
location with desert
snow you know snow high desert low
desert
redwoods badlands you know we we planted
out
that route and then we we we um
scheduled the production according to
the season so for
for us um and then once we got there
it's really up to josh
to to find the most iconic image that
can represent
that place and then um you know in the
edit is trying to figure out
how to make us to feel like a year has
passed
with those little short montage and
having the
the diversity of space and seasons
was the only way to make that possible
molly your cast is made up of
seasoned performers like frances
mcdormand and david strathearn but also
some non-professional actors who are so
fantastic how did you go about
finding all of them um well i can speak
to
to both the beef harvest and and i guess
the the rtr
um van dwellers that were there so um
for the rtr um we it took a few months
of
of gathering um names and people that
would be interested in being in the
movie and they were
it was through jessica's connections and
then
um suanne carlson who does the
five-gallon bucket lesson
in the rtr she was a really great
connector to the people that would be
interested and kind of called all that
together along with
pictures of their of their rigs um so so
they were kind of being cast as
people but also with their with their
vehicles um
and then had that all together so that
then um
chloe could then choose the people speak
to all the people
um on on set or prior to to the shoot
and decide then who she wanted to
to um to highlight i think the crazy
thing like in thinking about
non-professional performers
is people people are always asking this
question of like what is it like working
with non-professional performers
and i don't find the question that
interesting because i think we as
filmmakers treat them as
performers and they're part of our troop
and our in our
process and but one small
like one small nuance on a production
level that
molly remind me of is how you do have to
schedule around their work schedules
and how uh that is and so the the
casting team and led by molly and a
couple of others would do this advanced
work of casting
and chloe would be like okay i'm
interested in chloe and josh and say i'm
interested in these and these people
and we'd have to go and figure that out
with their actual work schedules
well one of the non-professional actors
that we do meet who's been mentioned
already is bob wells so the next clip
that we're going to show
is a great scene between fern and bob
wells which leads into
a wonderful tracking shot that we all
know from the teaser trailer
that you released from nomad land so
let's take a look at this clip
and then we'll talk more about it on the
other side
i can't imagine what you're going
through the
loss of your husband and the loss of
your whole town
and friends and village and that kind of
kind of loss is never easy
and uh i wish i had an easy answer for
you but
i think you've come to the right place
to find an answer i think that
i think connecting to nature and
to a real true community and tribe will
make all the difference for you
i hope so
thank you
[Music]
be back soon
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
joshua that tracking shot seems like
it's so
organic and effortless but my
understanding is that it was actually
quite
complex can you tell me about everything
that went into getting that
right sure um
yeah i mean i think it's a great shot to
focus on in terms of
what everyone did on the on the movie
no madland like the whole the whole crew
who are a part of like creating
something that feels
organic like it's it's happening
spontaneously yet
we're capturing it with a more sort of
cinematic
gaze somehow and then we kind of
had a really specific idea with the
light that we wanted
i'd take a note a few days previously of
the way the sun
kind of vanished behind the the
mountains of our location and uh
me and my gaffer we took an exact note
of
just when that sun was on the hill
because it kind of it still gave
everyone this
backflight but at the same time it was
soft enough because i knew i was
exposing for the sky
so whilst we were waiting for the light
um
there's a lot going on our our id mary
kerrigan is setting
the background all of our nomads had
specific actions and
cues um all of the vans
and rigs have been placed in specific
locations to
kind of create the depth that we wanted
but also
that you can see back there and you can
chloe is just allowing us to
breathe in this sort of world and these
these lives of these people
so i just think it's a good shot that
demonstrates some of the
kind of classic um influences we had
but also something that feels very new
and very of this time
and that's where the ronin 2 gimbal
comes in
because um you know we had new tools
like that
that was doing just what hal ashby and
um you know
house uh axel vessler were doing back in
the day
but nowadays we have this um technology
that means it's so
it's so much lighter and nimble so it
really and
allowed us on nomad land to to
to kind of maintain a real sort of
elegant
cinematic sensibility yet move really
quick and get the camera inside of these
real and orchestrated uh
situations chloe from your point of view
it's really it's really good to maybe
bring it into into that point
uh how many people were in our company
and how many people
how few people were actually
orchestrating that
shot because it just it's i i kind of
like the idea of just you know
letting the big uh big crews know how
how fast and easy and
nimble a smaller crew can be i would
also add to that as you described it
uh josh the feeling of anxiety i was
getting at my stomach as you redescribed
it
the light all the nomads who've never
done this before and they all each have
a job and they've got to hit it and you
know and all of it and it's just
like the the the wizardry or whatever
little pixie dust was there to
help sort of move that along the gods of
cinema smiled
uh i guess chloe did it feel like a very
special shot
in the moment how did you want to
utilize the whole golden hour
atmosphere we call it the magic hour
hustle
so the crew members months after the
shoot
would tell me so around four o'clock i
started to feel anxious in my stomach
i don't know why but i feel like
something needs to happen so there's a
there's
um it takes a lot of commitment for for
everyone
and and our and our company to take that
leap of faith
every day to say we're going to trust
the people that we're filming we're
going to trust the weather we're going
to trust everything is going to the
equipment
that we're going to wait until the right
time i think josh used to say that um
a magic a sunset is one how
we are supposed to look like as people
or something like well i forgot the
phrase it's like everything just blend
together
us and the world when we others around
us suddenly the edges
dissolve and we all become one and
that's why the sunsets are so important
for so many cultures you know inspire so
many
spirituality in religion it's for that
reason and i think
sometimes with the films that are made
they're people who live in the
peripheral of society
and sometimes they're they're captured
in very harsh journalistic lenses
you know or from news you know it's a
camera with with very
unforgiving and i think it's really
important for us to
to put a cinematic lens in on their in
their lives because that's how they fern
feels when she step out the
her her uh her van and uh that's what
she sees
what she sees is more beautiful than we
can actually ever capture
right but we try our best to do it so
people understand why
they chose that lifestyle molly the
tracking shop
magic hour shot that we all have been
talking about takes place at an event
called the rubber tram rendezvous rtr as
as it's referred to as you referred to
it
can you just tell everyone watching and
listening to this about the importance
of that event
sure yeah i mean a lot of the van
dwellers
it can be a very solitary life and but
there's once
once a year um they're all kind of come
together
to this area in quartzite um where
they share different tips
um but it also is a place of community
too where
um because like i said it could
sometimes be a very solitary life
they cannot they can all be together and
so we were
um we were staging this to be an early
an early rtr
so from so where it only started out
because
like 50 people um and we
and so we staged this to be right before
the real rtr which has now grown to be
i think that year it was 10 000 people
came together
um and so we we gathered these these 50
people in their vehicles and then
you know staged it and they actually
lived you know
they actually kind of created their own
movie rtr because like when we left with
the camera they were all living there
and and so i think that that also added
to this lived in feeling because they
literally were
living there and creating a community
dan from a production point of view was
there something particularly
difficult or challenging about
recreating the
rtr i i certainly think it was the most
challenging
production standpoint that we took on as
a team
um to me i think it speaks to
the magic of the film is the degree to
which you should have no idea what is
staged and what is reality
and i think one of the themes of the
conversation is the degree to which
we go to great lengths for you not to
know that so
rtr stands out as the single
biggest production or art challenge that
we took on in the film
because as molly said we completely
staged it from scratch and the whole
idea was for it to feel like an rtr
i think that there's a lot of practical
considerations to go into that
and to me it's a fascinating part of the
process of working with chloe because
what's amazing about how i think
she makes movies is that it was a
legitimate conversation of do we
actually
shoot at the real rtr and there were a
lot of reasons we didn't
the first one as molly said is story
based because
the current rtr is just too big for when
our story takes place
but i think there's a much broader point
that that connects back to the tracking
shot of
is we actually want to be able to
control
real environments for a cinematic
practice that's not documentary based
and so i think if you combine the
production infrastructure
of staging this huge undertaking which i
think our crew would take
huge pride in with the tracking shot
to me it's kind of emblematic of how
many layers of reality
we're playing with at every moment of
the film and i don't think any of this
has to do with the experience
the viewer should not be thinking about
that but
from a behind-the-scenes perspective i
think it's a fascinating
experience i have one last question for
chloe
can you tell me a little bit about how
the script
may have changed or evolved after you
cast and got to know some of the real
life nomads that are
in the movie how did the script change
to suit them
because they are playing versions of
themselves
yeah i mean the there is one main
um emotional journey for fur
and then and then you know she brunch
out a little bit here and there and
that's where all the other characters
comes in so
so as i meet swanky and then i met with
bob
and then my derrick and every time i
meet someone i get
and then they would tell me a lot about
their lives and then there are certain
parts
of their lives i go oh that i think
that's going to fit into this part of
fern's life
right and i have to i have to tweak what
fern is doing
as well so then so everything is sort of
puzzled together that way
and to me i i don't i think it will
always be this way when i make films i
don't think the script will lock until
last day of shooting um it could be
challenging for
for for the producing team for the cast
but um
yeah i don't know it's uh it's uh it's
the only way i know how to make films so
far
well whatever you all did it worked and
it worked beautifully
and i really appreciate you taking the
time to talk about nomad land
with me for everyone watching so thank
you to
chloe francis mcdormand joshua james
richards
dan janby peter spears molly asher and
thank you all so much
for watching take care thank you bye
bye